how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything do
with livestock well I'll tell you what
you're my kind of people because I grew
up on a farm in West st. Louis County
and we start out with beef calves and if
you raise livestock the only way to make
money is if you raise a lot of your own
feed for those of you don't have that
experience and so we raised our own corn
and we raised our own soy beans in our
own hay and we had a truck come out from
the mill and this truck would come out
from the mill and it would grind up the
corn and the soybeans and the hay and
then we would add sacks of vitamins
minerals trace minerals and we make
pellets out of it and this is what we
would feed the calves in six months time
we'd ship them to market to be
slaughtered we'd save back some of the
best ones for herself we'd knock him in
the head kneed him put it bluntly and it
always fascinated me as a teenager that
we did that for those calves and and six
months shipped them off to be
slaughtered or we'd eat them and we
wanted to live to be a hundred years of
age without any aches and pains and
guess what we didn't take any vitamins
or minerals and that bothered me so I
asked my dad I'd say hey pops how come
you do that for those calves you don't
do that for us and he'd give me this
good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd say
things like shut up boy you're getting
this farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it and course I was very
quiet then because I didn't want to miss
out on any meals well then when I went
to school I went to the University of
Missouri School of Agriculture and I got
my degree in agriculture I got my major
and animal husbandry in nutrition my
minor was in field crops and soils then
I got into veterinary school as a
freshman veterinary student I've learned
to answer to my question and the answer
is this we know how to prevent and cure
diseases and animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical
we don't have hospitalization BlueCross
BlueShield we don't have Medicare if
you're gonna make money as a farmer you
better know how to do stuff yourself and
you better do it efficiently with feed
and nutrition if you can to make a long
story short after I got out of
veterinary school I went to Africa for
two years and I was able to fulfill a
boyhood dream I was a
be a Frank buck for two years and worked
with Marlon Perkins many of you will
remember him from the mutual of Omaha's
Wild Kingdom and is a great gentleman
and after two years of working with
elephants and rhinos people used to ask
me or are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet while I was telling my
max tree large animal vet as I worked
with elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the st. Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we were given a seven and a half
million dollar grant from the National
Institutes of Health and what we need is
a veterinarian who'll do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo well I was just overjoyed to do
that and so I came back and and of
course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the st. Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
Bronx Zoo in New York the National Zoo
the LA Zoo and so forth and my job again
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the zoo and look
for a species of animals it was ultra
sensitive to pollution this becuase
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and ecological problems
and disasters and nobody quite knew what
to do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals it was extra
sensitive and used them much like we did
the Canaries in the mine you know the
old Welsh coal miners used to put a
canary in a little wicker cage and take
it down in the mine and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine the canary would drop off the perch
and die first and the man knew to get
out before the mine blew up are they
suffocated again to make a long story
short over a period of some 12 years I
did 17,500 autopsies and over 454
species of animals and 3,000 human
beings who lived in close proximity to
zoos and the thing that I found out was
this every animal and human being who
dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency and that
fascinated me went back took me back to
those cows I said gee that's fascinating
we could document this at autopsy both
chemically and biochemically and things
you saw with the eye at the autopsy
table
well that fascinated me and I wrote
scientific articles I wrote
2-8 multi-author textbooks in one
textbook of my own cause 140 bucks for
medical students and I'm sure the only
thing they do is use them for doorstops
and it couldn't get anybody excited I
was on 20/20 I was on 1,700 newspapers I
was in magazines it was in every network
TV that you can think of and guess what
couldn't get anybody excited back in the
60s about nutrition so what I did was
went back to school and became a
physician to use everything I'd learned
in veterinary school about nutrition and
my human patients and to no surprise to
me it worked
spent 12 years up in Portland Oregon and
general practice and it's very
fascinating what I'm going to share with
you tonight is what I learned over those
10 12 years using nutrition with my
human patients and if you take home only
10% it will save you an enormous amount
of unnecessary misery it will save you a
gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a gob
means a lot okay it'll add many
healthful years to your life
well you can't do this you can't get
these healthful years you can't have
longevity you can't live to your genetic
potential just falling off a stump
you have to do some things and the first
thing I have to do is convince you that
it is worth doing these things I'm gonna
start out by convincing you that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 years our genetic potential for
longevity and may 11th the oldest living
American at this time and documented
through the Guinness World Book of
Records was Margaret skeet she was from
Radford Virginia she died at age 115 and
she died of a nutritional deficiency
tell that from her obituary as she died
at the complications of a fall what does
she die from osteoporosis very good she
died of a calcium deficiency she had no
heart disease no cancer no diabeetus no
other infirmities but she died three
weeks after a fall because she didn't
have enough calcium her daughter said
that she had a craving for sweets until
she died and that's a disease called
pica we'll talk about that a little bit
but usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocoholic or a
sugar or holic
means that you have a deficiency have
been in a third world country and Niger
in Africa a chief by the name of Bauer
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives and she was bragging about him at
his death at age 126 he was still in
possession of all his own teeth okay so
you assume that other faculties are
working too then here's a gentleman from
Syria at age 133 he died in July of 1993
he fathered nine children after the age
of 80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child in a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellows then those of you who like
science in November of 1993 those six
biosphere Ian's
came out of that dome in Arizona they
were in there for two years three
couples and they were supposed to eat
the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out there examined by medical
gerontologist from UCLA University of
California Los Angeles they put all this
information their physical their blood
work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA and the medical
computers projected that they could live
to be a hundred and sixty-five years old
if they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be a hundred and twenty and
when I grew up on the farm we could grow
200 bushels of corn per acre and with
all the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew 200 bushels per acre
but if you only got a hundred bushels
per acre and put out that same effort in
the same fertilizer cause you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is seventy five point five the
average lifespan for an MD here a doctor
is 58 when he gained 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120
there's only two basic things it real
simple two things remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those are in the military you know
that means you do something stupid like
step on one of those things you kill
yourself wastefully or unnecessarily and
of course if you play Russian roulette
or smoke excessively or drink
excessively or wear a black sweatshirt
and run down the middle of the highway
of two o'clock in the morning you're
going to get struck by a car all of
those things are foolhardy but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines
I'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors and I'm going
to back up that statement which is a
pretty strong statement from Ralph
Nader's group in January of 1993 just
about a year and a half ago January 13th
he put out a news release based on a
3-year study on the causes of death in
American hospitals and it was fifteen
hundred page report this three year
study and I'm not going to waste your
time or mine by going over the whole
thing work forward but the bottom line
says a lot quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote I'm
going to read that figure again because
it's a huge figure quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote he didn't say slipped
away quietly out of neglect in a corner
somewhere while they're waiting for an
x-ray
he's the word killed when you used the
word killed that means there was a
procedure the doctor was doing went
wrong somehow that means that they gave
them a wrong prescription they put a
decimal point in the wrong spot and gave
them an incorrect dosage these people
were killed 300,000 to appreciate how
big a figure that is you have to compare
that with our military losses in Vietnam
over 10 years where we lost 56 thousand
people over ten years or an average of
only five thousand six hundred a year on
a field of battle where people had guns
and artillery and explosives trying to
kill each other and millions of people
poured out into the streets and
protested that war we had political
anarchy in the last three years of the
war students took over universities and
colleges with guns
explosives National Guardsmen shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel year and here's
one profession that takes your tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300,000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader and I believe he me as no
axe to grind and you can go out on the
street any day of the week in any city
and there isn't even a crazy street
preacher out there with a sign that says
protect us from doctors I want you to
think about that folks that's number one
you have to avoid stepping on the
landmines so there's a certain value and
treating yourself when you can while
preventing disease they don't have to
get treated now the second thing you
have to do number two is you have to do
the positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board and it's the number ninety and
you need 90 nutrients in your diet every
day you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're gonna get a deficiency
disease if you don't have them in
complete numbers and optimal amounts I
can tell you that I was one of those
nerds back when I was in college I had a
clipboard we didn't have computers back
then so I had a clipboard and I was one
of those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the Student
Union there in Columbia and say do you
take vitamins and minerals I'm still
fascinated by that and and of course
people kind of look at you're crazy and
say well yeah I take vitamin E and I'd
wait for him to come up with the other
89 and they didn't they just so I take
vitamin E well today if you ask people
do you take food supplements they say oh
yeah I take tums because that's what you
know they hear all the time well again
you need 90 nutrients if you're gonna
make it but the newspaper is no and then
magazines and TV and radio knows that
we're interested in health and longevity
and and supplements so they all talk to
us not because the medical profession
has asked them to do that in their stead
the medical profession doesn't say hey
we're so busy saving people with surgery
and chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition
they do it because it sells newspapers
well my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time magazine April 6th 1992
and if you haven't read it I'd urge you
to get it out of a school library of
public library and photocopy it stick
one copy on the door in the bathroom and
one on the refrigerator it's a cover
article and it says the real power of
vitamins new research shows they may
help fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of aging again there's six
positive pages in here there's only one
negative sentence and was issued by a
medical doctor who is asked by the
writer of the article what do you think
what do you think about vitamins and
minerals for people as food supplements
and here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do any good
sniffs dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right after having done those 17,500
autopsies and 454 species of animals
from around the world and then 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren in
the not-too-distant future children I'd
rather pee out 50 cents or dollar day
worth of excess vitamins and minerals is
pretty cheap insurance if you don't
invest in yourself to the tune of a buck
a day for vitamins and minerals guess
what you're gonna invest in the
lifestyle of an MD somewhere because
when you pay the medical doctor your fee
for going to see him not one penny of
that goes to study how to diagnose or
treat or prevent the catastrophic
disease and a little child like who is
in here earlier or how to prevent or
diagnose or treat better breast cancer
prostate cancer and adults guess what
that money goes for our pays the
doctor's mortgage makes his Mercedes
payment it pays the tuition for his kids
to go to medical school at have it you
know have
Bastin pays it tuition for his kids to
go to law school at Yale between 1776 in
the Second World War the US government
spent 80 million dollars on health care
and health care research and studies
right now we're 1.2 trillion dollars a
year for health care and it's free we
all know it's free right it's not free
but we're supposed to believe it's free
and everybody wants more of it and more
free stuff well tell you what if we used
a human-type medical system for the
agricultural industry and the livestock
your hamburger caused 275 dollars a
pound on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be $10 a month you take your
choice well I believe since we've made
them wealthy through insurance programs
and government subsidies I believe they
owe us something I believe they owe us
at least as much as the industry's do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph Nader learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
Pinto car with a rear end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 miles an hour
fry everybody in the car and when people
complain to Ford Motor Company they said
well you're just dumb for getting in a
car accident we're not going to pay you
for that well Ralph Nader says no it's a
faulty design so he went to a federal
court and the judge agreed with him and
through a court order forced Ford Motor
Company to send everybody a recall
notice with a registered letter bring
that car in and we'll fix it for nothing
but they killed 300,000 a year nobody
protests as long as we get are as free
and that scares me that attitude in a
rate I've got a bunch of these recall
notices you should have gotten over the
last couple of years we'll go through
them quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibbin right
well we knew fifty years ago and in the
veterinary industry that ulcers at least
in pigs was caused by bacteria called
Helicobacter pylori and of course we
couldn't get one of these high priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo
when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be $275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery and so that's what we
did cost five bucks to cure a pig of
stomach ulcers with bismuth the trace
mineral and tetracycline well the
National Institutes of Health now not
the National Enquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called Helicobacter pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do
that they always say it shows promising
results or may be beneficial they use
the Cure word National Institutes of
Health and they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and tetracycline well for those of you
don't know what business comes in you
can get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about 295 for an
eight ounce bottle and it's called
pepto-bismol so a teaspoon a day full of
pepto-bismol and some Ora mice and calf
scaler pellets you can take care of
sorts now you have your choice where
you're going to treat your own for five
bucks or go get whittled on it's your
choice
then what's the number two cause of
death and Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that when they send you that
bill they should send you some photo
copies of this stuff well in September
of 1993 the National Cancer Institute
not the National Enquirer but the
National Cancer Institute and the havehd
medical school up in Boston this study
on cancer patients and they came out and
they said an anti-cancer diet was found
well any rate they've picked China to do
this study because in one province Henan
Province in China they have the highest
rate of cancer in the whole world
they took 29,000 people for five years
in this study and what they did was give
them different vitamins and minerals
at double the recommended daily
allowance for Americans now that's a
trivial amount for instance they use
vitamin C for one group and of course
the RDA recommended daily allowance for
vitamin C is 60 milligrams double
density 120 milligrams you can't go into
a health food store and find a vitamin C
tablet or capsule for less than 500
milligrams for an adult and of course
Linus Pauling the gentleman was two
Nobel Prizes says if you want to prevent
and treat cancer with vitamin C you got
to use 10,000 milligrams a day well all
the doctors used to argue with him back
thirty five years ago were all dead and
today Linus Pauling still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day seven days a week
on his ranch in the Big Sur in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the dead doctors or
Linus Pauling your choice okay vitamin C
double the RDA nothing happened vitamin
A double the RDA nothing happens zinc
riboflavin the trace mineral molybdenum
nice and nothing happened in one group
they got a major benefit in this group
they got three nutrients at one time
they got vitamin E
they got beta-carotene and the trace
mineral selenium there those three were
at double the RDA and if you get a half
a percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major improvement in humanity's life and
so these articles get published so once
you remember that statistic a half a
percent is major benefit well in this
group that received the vitamin D
beta-carotene and selenium for five
years deaths from all causes were
reduced by nine percent almost ten out
of every hundred or one out of every ten
who were going to die in that five years
from any cause survived then cancers all
cancers thirteen percent survived who
would have died without those three
nutrients so thirteen out of a hundred
lived who would have died and in the
type of cancer that was most prevalent
in henan province stomach and esophageal
cancer 21 percent lived who would have
died 21 out of a hundred lived now to me
those are significant numbers and your
physician for the number two cause of
death in America should have sent every
one of you a photocopy that at least
given the information even if he doesn't
want to give you the advice give you the
information let you
your own mind well here's one I think is
funny on one hand and on the other side
it tells you the attitude of physicians
this has to do with arthritis it was in
September 24th 1993 that it was released
again it was from the habit Medical
School in the past and VA hospital how
many of you in here have ever been to a
VA hospital anybody in this room okay
good well you know the people who've
been to a VA hospital we have two
opportunities to give your life for your
country
once on the field of battle and the
others in the VA hospital right well
narrate the title of the release was
chicken protein halts the swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mezzo Trek's eight they got
aspirin prednisone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery okay now
before Harvard Medical School the VA
hospital was going to give it to them
they said look we're looking for some
people who are willing to suffer for 90
more days just three months because we
want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of ground-up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in ten
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment in 30 days
they could open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened and ninety days three
months they had maximum return of
function here's the funny part
the funny part comes by a statement of
the guy who was the director of that
study from Harvard Medical School and
here's what he said quote listen to the
words a very important quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you can just see him calculating right
that means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a license and if you go
to a Kentucky Fried Chicken in the
middle of the night and the dark of the
night you go to their dumpster and your
route through there and you collect two
5-gallon feed buckets full of chicken
bones and you take them home with a
hammer and you pound off the ends of
those bones and dry your own cartilage
in the microwave you know you're
manufacturing a pharmaceutical and the
FDA is gonna put you in jail next time I
come by here in three months you're
gonna run up on this station hug me and
kiss me if you got arthritis how many
you've ever heard of alzheimers disease
everybody's heard about it today 50
years ago when I was a little kid
there's no such thing as alzheimers
disease it's a new disease one of those
things that just sort of happened now
it's a major disease one out of every
two people who reach age 70 get
alzheimer's disease it's pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages a Alzheimer's disease in
livestock you imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their head saying why
am I here where is the feed box because
if they're not gaining a couple of
pounds a day you're losing money right
so we learned in the agricultural
industry how to prevent in the early
stages cure Alzheimer's disease and we
do it with high doses of vitamin E and
low intakes of vegetable oil you say
well like that's crazy high doses of
vitamin E well you should have got a
recall notice from your doctor in July
of 1992 because the University of
California I mean we're talking about a
sophisticated research medical school
here University of California San Diego
came out and said vitamin E eases memory
loss and Alzheimer's victims now there
are only 50 years behind on that from
veterinary medicine so he might be safer
going to a veterinarian then how many of
you in this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidneys
give up calcium no dairy no dairy
none of those vitamin mineral things
with calcium in them because they have
the stupid naive ignorant belief as
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones in livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more boron
the reason is of course bulls and Rams
male cattle and sheep have a special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they died they called water belly they
died when you and I get a kidney stone
we just wish we were dead but no farmer
is dumb enough to pay for the feed for
an animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your urologist should
have sent a notice to you
this was March of 1993 it says calcium
limits kidney stone risk and this is
from the have't medical school up in
Boston by the way in a study that turns
conventional medical wisdom on its head
researchers have found that people whose
diets are rich in calcium run a reduced
risk of developing kidney stones and is
studied more than 45,000 people though
who were ranked into five categories the
group that had the most calcium had no
kidney stones now about five years ago
when I started out on this crusade and
started lecturing to people all across
America and I'm in one timezone in the
next and all over I knew I was gonna get
crazy out there doing this last year I
was on the road 300 days out of the year
300 out of 365 days and so I decided I
needed to have a hobby that I could take
with me every time I get a little wacko
I could go in my room and do this hobby
and I'd be okay you know be kind of like
to having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went I wanted to have a hobby
that would help other people I didn't
want to collect baseball cards because I
like football and I didn't want to do
just crossword puzzles because good
mental exercise but wouldn't help
anybody else and I couldn't take my
compost pile I like the garden and the
hotels don't like that you know
so I decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers
now as crazy as that sounds remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we live to seventy five
point five and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average anybody got a few of them here
some of my favorites so this dr. Stuart
Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead in his
home he was a family practitioner of a
ruptured aneurysm that's a ballooning of
an artery that's a weakened artery
because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries just like when you hit a
chuckhole with your car tire and you
break the cords in there and you get a
balloon he dropped dead like he was pull
axed okay right in his home from a
ruptured aneurysm and we learned in 1900
I think it was 57 aneurysms are caused
by a copper deficiency we had a pilot
project turkeys we made complete food
pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs and their autopsy and they found
out that they all had died from a
ruptured aortic aneurysm so they doubled
the amount of copper in there and the
next year they didn't lose a single
turkey from a ruptured aortic aneurysm
and they ran that experiment in mice and
rats and rabbits and dogs and cats and
calves and sheep and pigs and whatnot
and guess what they found out there's a
whole series of diseases that are caused
by a copper deficiency gray hair is the
first sign we started getting gray hair
regardless of your age you got a copper
deficiency you got skin wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin are
going those little crow's feet around
your eyes and facial and body skin
wrinkles you look like you're a little
prune drying up okay then of course
there's the varicose veins that's caused
by an elastic fiber breakdown then of
course parts of your body begin to sag
under your arms your breasts your
bellies your legs all this stuff starts
sagging and you can go to a cosmetic
surgeon or plastic surgeon if you want
but it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer if he just
takes some copper
dr. Cartwright may have had a medical
degree but he didn't have expensive
urine so he died of something that even
a turkey wouldn't die from then here's
one this fellow he was a doctor's doctor
dr. Martin Carter he almost made it he
died at age 57 he got his medical degree
from havehd medical school and his PhD
in medicine from Yale
he was autopsies by the best because he
was a doctors doctor said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm said dr. Jules Hirsch the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either and here's an attorney
she was so famous she was from Detroit
age 44 Ellen Joyce altar she was in the
New York Times obituary she made the big
time and of course she probably had
steel buns because she belong to one of
those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little exercises but she didn't
have expensive urine because she died of
a ruptured cerebral aneurysm when they
don't do an autopsy the symptoms could
be called a stroke or subdural
hemorrhage but very frequently they're
caused by a ruptured aneurysm which is a
copper deficiency she didn't have
expensive urine how many of you were
here I've ever heard of a guy by the
name is Stuart Berger Stuart Berger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine Medical
School in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School and the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss
he wrote Forever Young 20 years younger
in 20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist and he died at age 40 how'd
you like to follow his dietary practices
he died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency the same
causes white muscle disease or our stiff
lamb disease and any farmer can go to a
feed store and get selenium pellets or
selenium injections of things like cell
Ataka and Bazzi and so forth and dr.
Stuart burger guy who wrote five
best-selling books on nutrition died of
a nutritional deficiency he didn't have
expense
of urine you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for ten cents a day and
if we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it your malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
cause 750 thousand dollars I want you to
think about that they get the heart free
from a donor they get the blood free for
the surgery from the relatives these two
dollars and fifty cents worth of suture
material and they charges seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for that
procedure now six months ago in LA when
they had the earthquake they were
putting people in jail for 60 and 90
days for price gouging for selling these
terrified people a gallon of water for
four dollars they put them in jail for
price gouging for selling them a gallon
of water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurial ism you know that's
being in business for yourself if you
had a way to distill water and make
water and you had a car and you could
get in there and sell those people a
gallon of water for four bucks a more
power to you because if you go to a
7-eleven and buy a quart of Evian water
it's a dollar twenty nine so four of
those quarts is a five bucks
hello I'm Rebecca Sain a former title
holder in the Miss and mrs. America
pageant systems and I'd like to welcome
you to the world of dr. Joel Wallach I'm
one of many who has been gifted with
restored health as a result of dr.
Wallach research and nutritional
products millions have heard his message
of health and long life others have
heard his message of nutrition and
longevity from his syndicated radio show
his books are as 300-plus speaking
engagements per year listen closely and
prepare to achieve your ultimate in good
health it is my privilege to introduce
researcher author lecturer and
world-renowned authority on health and
longevity dr. Joel wah
[Applause]
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything dude
livestock well I'll tell you what you're
my kind of people because I grew up on a
farm in West st. Louis County and we
start out with beef calves and if you
raise livestock the only way to make
money is if you raise a lot of your own
feed for those of you don't have that
experience and so we raised our own corn
and we raised our own soy beans in our
own hay and we had a truck come out from
the mill and this truck would come out
from the mill and it would grind up the
corn and the soybeans and the hay and
then we would add sacks of vitamins
minerals trace minerals and we make
pellets out of it and this is what we
would feed the calves at six months time
we'd ship them to market to be
slaughtered we'd say back some of the
best ones for herself we'd knock him in
the head kneed him put it bluntly and it
always fascinated me as a teenager that
we did that for those calves and then
six months ship them off to be
slaughtered or we'd eat them and we
wanted to live to be a hundred years of
age without any aches and pains and
guess what we didn't take any vitamins
or minerals and that bothered me so I
asked my dad I'd say hey pops how come
you do that for those calves you don't
do that for us and he'd give me this
good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd say
things like shut up boy you're getting
this farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it
and of course I was very quiet then
because I didn't want to miss out on any
meals well then when I went to school I
went to the University of Missouri
School of Agriculture and I got my
degree in agriculture I got my major and
animal husbandry in nutrition my minor
was in field crops and soils then I got
into veterinary school as a freshman
veterinary student I've learned to
answer to my question and the answer is
this we know how to prevent and cure
diseases and animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical we don't have
hospitalization BlueCross BlueShield we
don't have Medicare if you're gonna make
money as a farmer you better know how to
do stuff yourself and you better do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can to make a long story short after
I got out of veterinary school I went to
Africa for two years and I was able to
fulfill a boyhood dream I was able to be
a Frank buck for two years and worked
with Marlon Perkins many of
we'll remember him from the mutual of
Omaha's Wild Kingdom and is a great
gentleman and after two years of working
with elephants and rhinos people used to
ask me or are you a small animal vet or
a large animal vet while I was telling
my man extra large animal vet because I
worked with elephants and rhinos well
after two years he sent me a telegram
and said would you come back to the st.
Louis Zoo and work with us we need a
wildlife veterinarian at the zoo for a
special project we were given a seven
and a half million dollar grant from the
National Institutes of Health and what
we need is a veterinarian who'll do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the zoo well I was
just overjoyed to do that and so I came
back and and of course I not only did
autopsies for animals that died in the
st. Louis Zoo but the Brookfield Zoo in
Chicago the Bronx Zoo in New York the
National Zoo the LA Zoo and so forth and
my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo and look for a species of
animals that was ultra sensitive to
pollution this because during the early
60s we had just learned about pollution
and ecological problems and disasters
and nobody quite knew what to do and so
I was supposed to find a species of
animals it was extra sensitive and used
them much like we did the Canaries in
the mine you know the old Welsh coal
miners used to put a canary in a little
wicker cage and take it down in the mine
and if methane gas or carbon monoxide
would leak into the mine the canary
would drop off the perch and die first
and the men knew to get out before the
mine blew up are they suffocated again
to make a long story short over a period
of some 12 years I did 17,500 autopsies
and over 454 species of animals and
3,000 human beings who lived in close
proximity to zoos and the thing that I
found out was this every animal and
human being who dies of natural causes
dies of a nutritional deficiency and
that fascinated me I went back took me
back to those caves I said gee that's
fascinating we could document this at
autopsy both chemically and
biochemically and things you saw with
the eye at the autopsy table well that
fascinated me and I wrote scientific
articles I wrote eight multi-author
textbooks in one textbook of my own
cause 140 bucks for medical school
and I'm sure the only thing they do is
use them for door stops and it couldn't
get anybody excited I was on 20/20 I was
on 1,700 newspapers I was in magazines
it was in every network TV that you can
think of and guess what
couldn't get anybody excited back in the
60s about nutrition so what I did was
went back to school and became a
physician to use everything I'd learned
in veterinary school about nutrition of
my human patients and to no surprise to
me it worked
spent 12 years up in Portland Oregon in
general practice and it's very
fascinating what I'm going to share with
you tonight is what I learned over those
10 12 years using nutrition with my
human patients and if you take home only
10% it will save you an enormous amount
of unnecessary misery it will save you a
gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a gob
means a lot okay it'll add many
healthful years to your life well you
can't do this you can't get these
healthful years you can't have longevity
you can't live to your genetic potential
just falling off a stump you have to do
some things and the first thing I have
to do is convince you that it is worth
doing these things I'm gonna start out
by convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is 120 years
our genetic potential for longevity and
may 11th the oldest living American at
this time and documented through the
Guinness World Book of Records was
Margaret skeet she was from Radford
Virginia she died at age 115 and she
died of a nutritional deficiency you can
tell that from her obituary as she died
at the complications of a fall what does
she die from osteoporosis very good she
died of a calcium deficiency she had no
heart disease no cancer no diabeetus no
other infirmities but she died three
weeks after a fall because she didn't
have enough calcium her daughter said
that she had a craving for sweets until
she died and that's a disease called
pica we'll talk about that a little bit
but usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocoholic or a
sugar or holic that means that you have
a deficiency you've been in a third
world country and Niger in Africa a
chief by the name of Bauer at age
and 26 was eulogized by one of his wives
and she was bragging about him and his
deaf at age 126 he was still in
possession of all his own teeth okay so
you assume that other faculties are
working too then here's a gentleman from
Syria at age 133 he died in July of 1993
he fathered nine children after the age
of 80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child in a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellows then those of you who like
science in November of 1993 those six
biosphere Ian's came out of that dome in
Arizona they were in there for two years
three couples and they were supposed to
eat the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out there examined by medical
gerontologist from UCLA University of
California Los Angeles they put all this
information their physical their blood
work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA and the medical
computers projected that they could live
to be a hundred and sixty-five years old
if they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be a hundred and twenty and
when I grew up on the farm we could grow
200 bushels of corn per acre and with
all the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew two hundred bushels
per acre but if you only got a hundred
bushels per acre and put out that same
effort in the same fertilizer cause
you'd lose money and so I want you to
think about it the average lifespan for
an American today is seventy five point
five the average lifespan for an MD here
a doctor is 58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120
there's only two basic things it real
simple two things to remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those of you in the military you
know that means you do something stupid
like step on one of those things you
kill yourself wastefully or unnecessary
early of course if you play Russian
roulette or smoke excessively or drink
excessively or wear a black sweatshirt
and run down the middle of the highway
at two o'clock in the morning you're
going to get struck by a car all of
those things are foolhardy but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines
I'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors and I'm going
to back up that statement which is a
pretty strong statement from Ralph
Nader's group in January of 1993 just
about a year and a half ago January 13th
he put out a news release based on a
3-year study on the causes of death in
American hospitals and it was fifteen
hundred page report his three year study
and I'm not going to waste your time or
mine by going over the whole thing word
for word but the bottom line says a lot
quote 300,000 Americans are killed each
year in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence unquote I'm going to
read that figure again because it's a
huge figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote he
didn't say slipped away quietly out of
neglect in a corner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you used the word
killed that means there was a procedure
the doctor was doing went wrong somehow
that means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
ten years where we lost fifty six
thousand people over ten years or an
average of only five thousand six
hundred a year on a field of battle
where people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political anarchy in the last three
years of the war students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsmen shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel year and here's
one profession that takes your tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300,000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader and I believe he me as no
axe to grind and you can go out on the
street any day of the week in any city
and there isn't even a crazy street
preacher out there with a sign that says
protect us from doctors I want you to
think about that folks that's number one
you have to avoid stepping on the
landmines so there's a certain value and
treating yourself when you can while
preventing disease they don't have to
get treated now the second thing you
have to do number two is you have to do
the positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number ninety and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're gonna get a deficiency
disease if you don't have them in
complete numbers and optimal amounts I
can tell you that I was one of those
nerds back when I was in college I had a
clipboard we didn't have computers back
then so I had a clipboard and I was one
of those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the Student
Union there in Columbia and say do you
take vitamins and minerals I was still
fascinated by that and and of course
people kind of look at you're crazy and
say well yeah I take vitamin E and I'd
wait for him to come up with the other
89 and they didn't they just so I take
vitamin E well today if you ask people
do you take food supplements they say oh
yeah I take tums because that's what you
know they hear all the time well again
you need 90 nutrients if you're going to
make it but the newspaper is know and
then magazines and TV and radio knows
that we're interested in health and
longevity and and supplements so they
all talk to us not because the medical
profession has asked them to do that in
their stead the medical profession
doesn't say hey we're so busy saving
people with surgery and chemotherapy and
radiation and pharmaceuticals would you
please educate the people on nutrition
they do it because it sells newspapers
well my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time magazine April 6th 1992
and if you haven't read it I'd urge it
get it out of the school library or
public library and photocopy it stick
one copy on the door in the bathroom and
one on the refrigerator it's a cover
article and it says the real power of
vitamins new research shows they may
help fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of aging again there's six
positive pages in here there's only one
negative sentence and it was issued by a
medical doctor who is asked by the
writer of the article what do you think
what do you think about vitamins and
minerals for people is food supplements
and here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right after having done those 17,500
autopsies and 454 species of animals
from around the world and then 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren in
the not-too-distant future children I'd
rather pee out 50 cents or a dollar day
worth of excess vitamins and minerals is
pretty cheap insurance if you don't
invest in yourself to the tune of a buck
a day for vitamins and minerals guess
what you're gonna invest in the
lifestyle of a MD somewhere because when
you pay the medical doctor your fee for
going to see him not one penny of that
goes to study how to diagnose or treat
or prevent a catastrophic disease and a
little child like who was in here
earlier or how to prevent or diagnose or
treat better breast cancer or prostate
cancer in adults guess what that money
goes or pays the doctor's mortgage makes
his Mercedes payment it pays the tuition
for his kids to go to medical school at
have it you know have it is up and
Basten pays the tuition for his kids to
go to law school at Yale between 1776 in
the Second World War the US government
spent 80 million dollars on health care
and health care research and studies
right now we're one
point two trillion dollars a year for
health care and it's free we all know
it's free right it's not free but we're
supposed to believe it's free and
everybody wants more of it and more free
stuff well tell you what if we used a
human-type medical system for the
agricultural industry and the livestock
your hamburger caused 275 dollars a
pound on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be ten dollars a month you take
your choice well I believe since we've
made them wealthy through insurance
programs and government subsidies
I believe they owe us something I
believe they owe us at least as much as
the industry's do according to for
instance recall notices this was started
of course I don't know 25 years ago when
Ralph Nader learned that the Ford Motor
Company had made a Pinto car with a rear
end gas tank that would blow up when you
got hit from behind at 20 miles an hour
fry everybody in the car and when people
complain to Ford Motor Company they said
well you're just dumb for getting in a
car accident we're not going to pay you
for that well Ralph Nader says no it's a
faulty design so he went to a federal
court and the judge agreed with him and
through a court order forced Ford Motor
Company to send everybody a recall
notice with a registered letter bring
that car in and we'll fix it for nothing
but they killed 300,000 a year nobody
protests as long as we get are as free
and that scares me that attitude in a
rate I've got a bunch of these recall
notices you should have gotten over the
last couple of years we'll go through
them quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibbin right
well we knew fifty years ago and in the
veterinary industry that ulcers at least
in pigs was caused by bacteria called
Helicobacter pylori and of course we
couldn't get one of these high priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be $275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery so that's what we did
cost five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with bismuth the trace mineral in
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
National Enquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called Helicobacter pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do
that they always say it shows promising
results or may be beneficial they use
the Cure word National Institutes of
Health and they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and tetracycline well for those of you
don't know what business comes in you
can get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about 295 for an
eight ounce bottle and it's called
pepto-bismol so a teaspoon a day full of
pepto-bismol and some are mice and calf
scowler pellets you can take care of
sorts now you have your choice but
you're gonna treat your own for five
bucks or go get whittled on that's your
choice then what's the number two cause
of death and Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that when they send you that
bill they should send you some photo
copies of this stuff well in September
of 1993 the National Cancer Institute
not the National Enquirer but the
National Cancer Institute and the havehd
Medical School in Boston did study on
cancer patients and they came out and
they said an anti-cancer diet was found
well any rate they picked China to do
this study because in one province Henan
Province in China they have the highest
rate of cancer in the whole world
it took 29,000 people for five years in
this study
and what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals had
doubled the recommended daily allowance
for Americans now that's a trivial
amount for instance they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the RDA
recommended daily allowance for vitamin
C is 60 milligrams double that's gonna
be a hundred and twenty milligrams you
can't go into a health food store and
find a vitamin C tablet or capsule for
less than 500 milligrams for an adult
and of course Linus Pauling the
gentleman was two Nobel Prizes says if
you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C you got to use 10,000
milligrams a day well all the doctors
used to argue with him back thirty five
years ago we're all dead
and today Linus Pauling still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day seven days a week
on his ranch in the Big Sur in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the dead doctors or
Linus Pauling your choice okay vitamin C
double the RDA nothing happened vitamin
A double the RDA nothing happens zinc
riboflavin the trace mineral molybdenum
nice and nothing happened in one group
they got a major benefit in this group
they got three nutrients at one time
they got vitamin E
they got beta-carotene and the trace
mineral selenium there those three were
at double the RDA
and if you get a half a percent benefit
in any nutritional or pharmaceutical
experiment you've made a major
improvement in humanity's life and so
these articles get published so once you
remember that statistic a half a percent
is major benefit well in this group that
receive the vitamin D beta-carotene and
selenium for five years deaths from all
causes were reduced by nine percent
almost 10 out of every hundred or one
out of every ten who were going to die
in that five years from any cause
survived then cancers all cancers
thirteen percent survived who would have
died without those three nutrients so 13
out of a hundred lived who would have
died and in the type of cancer that was
most prevalent in henan province stomach
and esophageal cancer 21 percent lived
who would have died 21 out of a hundred
lived now to me those are significant
numbers and your physician for the
number two cause of death in America
should have sent every one of you a
photocopy that at least given the
information even if he doesn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information
let you make up your own mind well
here's one I think is funny on one hand
and on the other side it tells you the
attitude of physicians this has to do
with arthritis it was in September 24th
1993 that it was released again it was
from the habit medical school in the
Basten VA hospital how many of you in
here have ever been to a VA hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
hospital we have two opportunities to
give your life for your country
once on the field of battle and the
others in the VA hospital right well
narrate the title of the release was
chicken protein halts to swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mezzo Trek's eight they got
aspirin prednisone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery okay now
before Harvard Medical School the VA
hospital was going to give it to him
they said look we're looking for some
people who are willing to suffer for 90
more days just three months because we
want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of ground-up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in ten
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment in 30 days
they could open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened and ninety days three
months they had maximum return of
function here's the funny part
the funny part comes by a statement of
the guy who was the director of that
study from Harvard Medical School and
here's what he said quote listen to the
words a very important quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you could just see him calculating right
that means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a license and if you go
to a Kentucky Fried Chicken in the
middle of the night and the dark of the
night and you go to their dumpster and
your route through there and you collect
two 5-gallon feed buckets full of
chicken bones and you take them home
with a hammer and you pound off the ends
of those bones and dry your own
cartilage in the microwave you know
you're manufacturing a pharmaceutical
and the FDA is gonna put you in jail
next time I come by here in three months
you're gonna run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis
how many you've ever heard of alzheimers
disease everybody's heard about it today
50 years ago when I was a little kid
there's no such thing as alzheimers
disease it's a new disease one of those
things that just sort of happened now
it's a major disease one out of every
two people who reach age 70 get
Alzheimer's disease pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages a Alzheimer's disease in
livestock you imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their heads saying why
am I here
where is the feed box because if they're
not gaining a couple of pounds a day
you're losing money right so we learned
in the agricultural industry how to
prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say well like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss and
Alzheimer's victims now there are only
50 years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so he might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no dairy no
dairy
none of those vitamin mineral things
with calcium in them because they have
the stupid naive ignorant belief as
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones in livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more boron
now the reason is of course bulls and
Rams male cattle and sheep have a
special Anatomy when they get a kidney
stone they die they called water belly
they die when you and I get a kidney
stone we just wish we were dead but no
farmer is dumb enough to pay for the
feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to market so we learned how to prevent
those things well you should have got a
recall notice from your doctor
especially you people who've had kidney
stones your urologist should have sent a
notice to you this was March of 1993 it
says calcium limits kidney stone risk
and this is from the have't Medical
School up in Boston by the way in a
study that turns conventional medical
wisdom on its head researchers have
found that people whose diets are rich
in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones and studied
more than 45,000 people though who were
ranked into five categories
group that had the most calcium had no
kidney stones now about five years ago
when I started out on this crusade and
started lecturing to people all across
America and I'm in one timezone in the
next and all over I knew I was going to
get crazy out there doing this last year
I was on the road 300 days out of the
year 300 out of 365 days and so I
decided I needed to have a hobby that I
could take with me every time I get a
little wacko I could go in my room and
do this hobby and I'd be okay you know
be kind of like having a little piece of
home with me wherever I went I wanted to
have a hobby that would help other
people I didn't want to collect baseball
cards because I like football
and I didn't want to do just crossword
puzzles because a good mental exercise
but wouldn't help anybody else and I
couldn't take my compost pile I like the
garden and the hotels don't like that
you know so I decided I was going to
collect obituaries of doctors and
lawyers
now as crazy as that sounds remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we live to seventy five
point five and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average anybody got a few of them here
some of my favorites so this is dr.
Stuart Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead
in his home he was a family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm that's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened artery because of the
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers and arteries just
like when you hit a chuckhole with your
car tire and you break the chords in
there and you get a balloon he dropped
dead like he was poleaxed oh okay right
in his home from a ruptured aneurysm and
we learned in 1900 I think it was 57
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys we made complete food pellets
where you put all the 90 nutrients in
there and in the first 13 weeks fully
half of those turkeys died farmers were
out there every morning picking them up
by the bushel basket they took them to
the state diagnostic labs and their
autopsy and they found out that they all
had died from a ruptured aortic aneurysm
so they doubled the amount of copper in
there and the next year they didn't lose
a single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and they ran that experiment in
mice and rats and rabbits and dogs and
cats and calves and sheep and pigs and
whatnot and guess what they found out
there's a whole series of diseases that
are caused by a copper deficiency gray
hair is the first time we started
getting gray hair regardless of your age
you got a copper deficiency you got skin
wrinkles because the elastic fibers in
your skin are going those little crow's
feet around your eyes and facial and
body skin wrinkles you look like you're
a little prune drying up okay
then of course there's the varicose
veins that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course parts of your
body begin to Sag under your arms your
breasts your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want
but it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer he just takes
some copper
dr. Cartwright may have had a medical
degree but he didn't have expensive
urine so he died of something that even
a turkey wouldn't die from then here's
one this fellow he was a doctor's doctor
dr. Martin Carter he almost made it he
died at age 57 he got his medical degree
from have't medical school and his PhD
in medicine from Yale
he was autopsy by the best because he
was a doctors doctor said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm said dr. Jules Hirsch the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency C
he didn't have expensive urine either
and here's an attorney
she was so famous she was from Detroit
age 44 Ellen Joyce alter she was in the
New York Times obituary she made the big
time and of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little exercises but she didn't
have expensive urine because she died of
a ruptured cerebral aneurysm when they
don't do an autopsy the symptoms could
be called a stroke or subdural
hemorrhage but very frequently they're
caused by a ruptured aneurysm which is a
copper deficiency she didn't have
expensive urine how many of you were
here I've ever heard of a guy by the
name of stuart burger stuart burger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine Medical
School in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School and the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss
he wrote Forever Young 20 years younger
in 20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist and he died at age 40 how'd
you like to follow his dietary practices
he died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency the same
causes white muscle disease or are stiff
Lam disease and any farmer can go to a
feed store and get selenium pellets or
selenium injections of things like cell
attack and bosey and so forth
and dr. Stewart burger guy who wrote
five best-selling books on nutrition
died of a nutritional deficiency he
didn't have expensive
you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it your malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
has 750,000 dollars I want you to think
about that they get the heart free from
a donor they get the blood free for the
surgery from the relatives these two
dollars and 50 cents worth of suture
material and they charges seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for that
procedure now six months ago in LA when
they had the earthquake they were
putting people in jail for 60 and 90
days for price gouging for selling these
terrified people a gallon of water for
four dollars they put them in jail for
price gouging for selling them a gallon
of water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurial ISM you know that's
being in business for yourself if you
had a way to distill water and make
water and you had a car and you could
get in there and sell those people a
gallon of water for four bucks a more
power to you because if you go to a
7-eleven and buy a quart of Evian water
it's a dollar twenty nine so four of
those quarts is a five bucks kind of
interesting isn't it they said it's
price gouging because those people were
terrified we'll talk about a person who
needs a new heart they're terrified
750,000 dollars we should put those
doctors in jail but we bow to him
because all that's high-tech medicine
out of 270 million people in America you
save about 50 a year is that
cost-effective I don't think so
dr. Stuart Berger didn't have expensive
urine here's the last one and many of
you may know this woman her name is dr.
Gail Clark she was aged 47 she was the
chief cardiologist at the West st. Louis
County group of hospitals she was the
chief cardiologist for the st. Mary's
health center in Richmond Heights in st.
Louis County she's aged 47 guess what
she died from heart attack a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you can just
see her walking down the hall she's got
the stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket when
she falls down she has a heart attack
right in the hall and of course the
nurses scooped her up and put her on a
gurney and they call the technicians in
another die
code 3 code 3 code blue whatever it is
and they whip her into the room and you
can hear him let's say you're a cardiac
patient you're laying there you're all
hooked up to the monitors and the IVs
and and you hear them say okay tear
clothes off okay stand back didn't work
turn it up stand back and then you hear
that terrible sound when you know that
the treatment didn't work the flatline
when you know the heart is gone and
everybody walks out of the room dejected
and you say nurse nurse
what happened next door and she says
well your cardiologist you know the
chief cardiologist of this hospital age
47 dr. Gail Clark just died of a cardiac
art attack we can see all the patients
are holding their gowns and they're
running out of that hospital leaving
their watches and their shoes and their
checkbooks and everything their plastic
credit cards because they don't want to
get with dr. Gail Clark got to me the
Reader's Digest is a magazine that never
says anything negative or bad about
anybody or any group
it's a sweetest little magazine that
ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your doctor
it lists 12 ways the doctors scam your
money and I'll let you read 11 of them
yourself I'll give you the worst one in
addition to their income from office
fees and surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the x-ray labs and
clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of 421 dollars every time they
send you in for a cat scan or an MRI and
doctors tell you all we do that because
we're practicing defensive medicine
because if I miss something you know 1
in 10 billion you're gonna sue me so I
do this just to protect myself well it
was just to protect themselves and you
knew them and they knew you 90% of the
people say oh I'll just skip it doc if
you don't really think it's necessary
let's save the money but they got
something more than defensive medicine
to worry about they get 421 bucks in a
kickback for every time they send you in
for an MRI or a cat scan well when I
practice for 12 years up in Portland
somebody come to me with a terrible
headache never had one I just walk up to
him and tap him on the sinuses and if
they collapsed to their knees I know
they had a sinus headache Oh doc why did
you do that well I wonder if that's a
cheap lab test you know
then if they had thank you if they had
blood dripping out of their nose that
take a $35 x-ray to see if they had a
cancer in their 35 bucks in a free lab
test as opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted
to make that 421 bucks I'd have been a
good thief what I'd have done I had to
build a chute right into that cat scan
machine because I knew how to build
chutes living on a farm and I did going
out in the street and I got every
homeless person I'd line them up in them
chutes and I'd put soup and a Big Mac at
the end of that tube you know and I say
I'm gonna get by you a dollar fifty
dinner I'm a good guy I'm gonna buy you
a dollar 50 dinner you just got to go
through this chute go through that tube
and you get your sandwich in your soup
man they'd be flowing through there
maybe a hundred a day and I can start
adding some things up it'd be a lot of
fun any rate the average doctor gets two
hundred and twenty eight thousand six
hundred and sixty dollars a year in
cat-scan kickbacks a quarter of a
million dollars a year and any other
industry if you do that politicians
lawyers businessmen stockbrokers they
get put in jail but doctors it's okay
because insurance pays for it we don't
mind if they steal is blind it's free
remember I told you I was gonna tell you
about Piko Piko is a funny disease P ICA
I'm going to talk about the type style
did you see in typewriters and computers
but Pike is a disease that farmers know
about in horses it's called cribbing
when they chew on the feed bunk the
wooden feed bunk
you know you better give him some
minerals otherwise they're gonna eat
that feed bunk and cattle dairy cattle
especially they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk all the time
intents of milking you'll see them
picking up big rocks in the creek and
chewing on them or they'll chew on Bob
wire or maybe you'll see them walking
down through a path with a deer bone in
their mouth or something or a shingle
that's called pica and a good farmer
husbandry man knows you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're gonna
eat the barn or something in human
beings we see this at funny times
pregnant women are notorious for pike ax
the middle of the night they'll elbows
their husband and say hey you better get
up I want some pickles and ice cream
they're craving minerals because that
fetus is pulling minerals out of their
body they need some more minerals and so
it's is recognized as a craving for
things like sweets and salt we see this
in pregnant women I used to have
people come to my practice and they say
doctor I need to go see a shrink I said
why is that well I wake up in the middle
of the night and I go outside with a
spoon and I eat dirt no that's okay
just make sure it's clean dirt then they
say my kid sits there with a kitty
litter box between his legs and he has a
spoon and he's eating that stuff I the
kitty litter box and then in housing
projects little kids will eat lead paint
off the walls and they get lead
poisoning at learning disabilities and
bone problems in a Nemean we're good so
we spend five million dollars to scrape
the lead paint off of there and repaint
it with latex paint we only have to do
is give those kids ten cents a day worth
of minerals be better farm and save us
five million bucks
it's your tax money and if we allow them
to throw them away those dollars is kind
of interesting if you have a selenium
deficiency and you don't want to wait
until you get to cardiomyopathy and drop
dead from a heart attack to recognize it
if you look on your hands and look in
the mirror in your face if you have
liver spots or age spots and I see quite
a few from here you have an early
selenium deficiency that's called free
radical damage and fortunately for you
if you recognize that and you start
taking in some selenium in four to six
months those will go away you'll reverse
that in four to six months and when they
go away on the outside they're going
away on the inside and your brain and
your heart in your liver and your
kidneys and if you have low blood sugar
how many in this room have a low blood
sugar anybody here I have low blood
sugar okay about 10% how many of you
ever seen a hyperactive kid who gets on
sugar okay about everybody in the room
people who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics there's good ones and bad
ones
you know the good alcoholics are one
when they get two drinks they just go
off in a corner and go to sleep
right same way that somebody with low
blood sugar they eat a big meal or they
eat a piece of pie three hours later
they clunk out and go to sleep
then there's bad alcoholics are the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody punch holes in the wall
you know big brave fellows and they kick
their wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor's tree
down and all these wild things and drive
reckless down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems there's bad
blood sugar people to be a little crazy
okay I don't know how many of you
remember the Twinkie defense
right remember if somebody murdered 2p
and he claimed he ate of Twinkie three
hours before he murdered them so they
let him off because he got temporarily
insane every time he ate sugar now don't
any of you try that
well chromium and vanadium deficiency
will result in these sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vanadium
then attend to fish and see the early
symptoms of a10 deficiency our male
pattern baldness I see a lot of ten
deficiency in this room yes and if you
let it go on for any length of time you
get deafness then there's a boron
deficiency and you guys should know
about boron because it helps you keep
the calcium you take in in your bones so
you don't get osteoporosis boron also it
helps you make estrogen it helps you
fellas make testosterone if you don't
take in enough boron you ladies are
gonna suffer miserably going through
menopause okay you're gonna have all
those terrible symptoms you fellas don't
get enough boron can't make testosterone
you won't know whether to lead or follow
on the dance floor
you're gonna be confused she's saying
he's got a boron deficiency the first
symptoms of a zinc deficiency as you
lose your sense of smell and your taste
say oh you know food just doesn't taste
good anymore you don't have a cold or
anything like that you say your wife
says well aren't you excited about
dinner I spent the whole day in the
kitchen cooking dinner he said well I
didn't smell anything when I walked in
you know he's got his ink deficiency
when laboratory animals there's some
seven rare earths these rare earths or
trace minerals you need in lesser
amounts than you need trace minerals and
they actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but I'm not going
to wait five hundred years for doctors
to approve it they're still arguing over
vitamin C and calcium right so I'm just
gonna do it didn't kill any laboratory
animals just doubles her life and it's
not a drug these rare earths are called
lanthanum precio d Miam neodymium
samarium europium ytterbium and thulium
there must be a reason why they're named
after old testament cities well remember
I told you we needed 90 nutrients we
need 60 minerals we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and of course
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but you have
to eat 15 to 25 different plants a day
in the right combinations to make this
happen theoretically it's possible but
most Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Crocker box or eaten
a vegetable in case they got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their doctor and they eat
low-fat turkey breasts and they put a
half a jar of mayonnaise on there and
they put it between two slices of wonder
styrofoam bread remember that stuff you
can insulate your house with and put
your shoes when you get a hold of shoe I
remember when I was a kid there's a lot
of fun because we have Wonder Bread we
didn't have TVs back then on the farm we
didn't even have dryers that went round
and round so the only thing you could do
in the wintertime was sit in the kitchen
and Wonder
a loaf of Wonder Bread and a head the
blue and red and green yellow balloons
on there and if you read the label as
many times as I do you know it said
things like helps build bodies at 12
weighs in about 15 years later the FDA
made them change it to help build your
body eight ways now if you go to the
store and look at Wonder bread wrappers
it just says Wonder Bread so it kind of
gives you a clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it's not likely
to happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids and
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 122 if
you don't you're just not going to do it
now minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because plants cannot make minerals in
any way shape or form and if they're not
in the soil anymore they're not in our
plants there are farms oils and our rain
soils are depleted of minerals in the
crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and rain soils or
mineral E deficient the people eat them
get mineral deficiency diseases and the
only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral supplements do you think
it's gotten any better no it has not
gotten any better it's only gotten worse
and the reason is if you guys do what we
did and people continue to do is we put
NPK on our land nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and you see it as these three
numbers in many combinations of ratios
and these represent percentages of these
three nutrients nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and those of you who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this as farmers get paid for
tons and bushels there's no subsidy that
encourages people to put 60 minerals
back in the soil you get paid for tons
and bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you
can get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes five to ten years
to deplete the land of minerals because
every time you harvest a crop those
plants pull minerals out of the soil
many pounds per acre every time you hold
a crop out so as soon those minerals are
gone and if you only put back in three
and you take out sixty it's like a
checking account if you only put three
bucks in your checking
every month and write checks for 60
what's going to happen to your checks
Boeing Boeing Boeing they bounce exactly
well I can tell you that our health is
bouncing right now to the tune of 1.2
trillion dollars a year it's our
responsibility each and every one of us
to be responsible for our health and
consciously take in these minerals I
have a lot of people ask me what did
these people do thousands of years ago
they didn't even have commercial
fertilizers what did they do these
societies that had long lived people and
whatnot I want you to think about the
Egyptians the Chinese people from India
that lived around these great rivers the
Nile River the Ganges River the Yellow
River in China and what used to happen
was every year or so it would flood just
like it did here in northern Missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from mountains from
five hundred or thousand miles away and
those people would pray to every God
they had the water God the sky God the
wind God the rock God to flood we pray
don't flood they used to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
wintertime and it would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
drain was very valuable King Phillip
who's the father of Alexander the Great
married the 12 year old child queen of
Egypt Cleopatra she didn't look like
Elizabeth Taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flat-chested teeny bopper not very sexy
but Phillip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great he needed the best
wheat in the world so you could march 20
hours a day fight for six hours and win
if they used the wheat from the depleted
soils in Greece they couldn't go 20
minutes without saying mommy pick me up
can you imagine these big Greek soldiers
oh my legs hurt pick me up and so they
knew the best place to get wheat was
from Egypt it was those floods that gave
them those minerals and all those
cultures that came up with all the great
art and all the great technology came
from those places because they had more
intelligence because it had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good we are getting the picture
well what I'm gonna do here is I'm just
gonna pick out a couple of minerals just
a couple of them so you get the idea it
applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
calcium deficiency will result in
something like a hundred and forty seven
different diseases they're just
different names are named after people
like Bell's palsy you know everybody
knows about that one side of your face
sags it's not as true stroke it just
affects your facial muscles it's caused
by a calcium deficiency we'll talk about
in a little bit but everybody knows
about this one osteoporosis it's the
number ten killer of adults United
States it's a very expensive it cost you
thirty five thousand dollars each for
each hip to replace it's okay it's free
insurance will pay for it cost you
seventy thousand dollars for both hips
as expensive as it is and the number ten
killer remember mister Skeets from
Radford Virginia aged 115 years of age
she died of complications of a fall we
don't have osteoporosis and animals and
it's because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a pasture with a hundred cows
in it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right because you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mowed the pasture and fertilize and
maintain the fence and fed the cows and
all this that in the other you don't
have any calves you can't pay back the
operating loan and make any money so you
call the vet out you say do I get rid of
these cows what happened here any
examines the college there's nothing
wrong with them says let me look at the
bull and said aha here's your problem
that bull has osteoporosis of both hips
can't breed the cows didn't have any
calves he said I'll tell you what though
he says you give me $70,000 he says I'll
put two new hips in that bull next year
you'll have some calves well the first
thing that farmer says is stand back doc
boom he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle
and well the kids are grinding the bull
up with a grinder and cutting roasts and
steaks off that bull the farmers chewing
on a strong saying now doc pushes
Stetson up a little bit and he says you
know I wasn't gonna pay a seventy
thousand dollars for that old boy says I
get a new bull every year for seventy
years for that he says but every once
while I get a bullet throws good calves
I'd like to keep him is there any way I
can prevent that osteoporosis thing for
happen to a good boy well yeah he says
if you'll give a bull calf ten cents
worth of calcium every day after he's
weaned he'll never get osteoporosis
first and away damn it doc you mean if I
give that bull ten
a day worth of calcium from the time
he's weaned I can prevent a $70,000
disaster oh yeah it's that simple
he says you mean I only have to do is
give up a half a cup of coffee a day to
do that he says yeah that's it he says I
choose that one he's I'll give up the
half a cup of coffee and that's what we
have to think like then there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs can't sheep pigs
horses lines and tigers and bears and
they don't get receding gums and they
don't floss now they do get funky breath
but they don't get receding gums well if
you want to smell some you just let a
camel breathe on you boy well the reason
we don't have receding gums in livestock
is because we've dealt with the
osteoporosis problem receding gums is
not a deficiency of flossing it's in
fact osteoporosis of the jaw bones and
of the facial bones so if you have Ginja
Vitus or receding gums you have advanced
osteoporosis those bones around your
teeth are melting away a little bit by a
little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away
then there's arthritis we talked about
that a little bit earlier remember the
chicken cartilage 85% of all arthritis
is caused by a co prosess of the joint
ends of the bones you're talking about
degenerative arthritis osteoarthritis
sciatica lumbago rheumatism all those
sorts of things they're caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones I want you to think about
something for a minute if you don't take
a pain reliever or an anti-inflammatory
for that arthritis let's say you get
arthritis of the hips you're going to
kind of favor that a little bit aren't
you you're gonna get a cane or a walker
or crutches
you're gonna favor it and so you don't
put any weight on it I want you to think
about that for just a second because
they don't want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more
let's say you didn't put the nut on that
oil pan real tighten all the oil drained
out and that light on the dashboard
comes on says I'm getting hot you better
give me some oil and that light
irritates you so you stop you open up
the hood you get your Clippers out you
know your fence clippers and you clip
the wire to that light you close the
hood and you just keep driving would you
do that to your tractor or your Mercedes
no you would but we take those pain
relievers for arthritis and we go out
there and square dance and do the Texas
two-step and do our five-mile walks in
our aerobics that pill works real good
doc because it killed my pain and you're
just wearing that thing off faster and
faster then your doctor is really gonna
get rich because you need joint
replacement surgery then there's
hypertension this is one of my favorites
so I'll put a star over here
hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up salt everybody knows
that when that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock earns
about that big a salt block no farmer is
gonna be economically viable if you
don't put a salt block out for your
livestock they're gonna die kind of your
veterinary bills are gonna go crazy but
we're supposed to believe that we don't
need salt you can get everything you
need out of your lettuce and your
whole-wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you
they took 30 million dollars of your tax
money and two years ago after 20 years
study they came out and said that they
took 5,000 people with high blood
pressure they took him off their
medication and put him on a reduced salt
diet a restricted salt diet and they all
died no big surprise but somebody got a
PhD degree and everybody was happy right
but when they looked at this results
they said that only ninety-nine point
seven percent of the people didn't get
any results from that before they died
0.3 percent did get some result drop
their blood pressure one point before
they died by restricting their salt so
the referees who judged that article
said oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients heat
salted peanuts and dill pickles and salt
their food to taste because it doesn't
matter
in fact worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt then they
had a control group with 5,000 people
with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of Calci
and they stopped the experiment in six
weeks because 85% of them were cured of
their high blood pressure just by
doubling their calcium intake now they
didn't cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication but what they did
was they went to the doctor he says you
don't need this medication anymore what
are you doing well I'm on this
experiment I double my calcium intake
anybody get a recall notice from your
doctor saying it's okay to salt your
food to taste and please do double your
calcium intake anybody get that not a
single one is very interesting then of
course there's insomnia that's where you
roll around all night when you wake up
in the morning you're more tired when
you went to bed that's insomnia of
course doctors have two treatments for
that they have Halcyon which is a
sleeping pill and they have barbiturates
they kill about 10,000 people a year
with overdoses of those things but
that's okay it's a prescription and
they're watching out for us and remember
George Bush when he went to Japan they
gave him some healthy on so he could
sleep on the way to Japan because of the
time difference and when he woke up one
of the side effects of Halcyon is nausea
and vomiting I don't know how you say it
in Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very presidential
yeah and so I'm sure that's why he lost
the election because he puked over that
Japanese ambassador and then of course
there's kidney stones and then there is
a bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits again physicians will tell you
the first thing to give up nutritionally
is calcium and dairy because they have
this foolish belief the stupid beliefs
the ignorant belief that the calcium in
kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs and
calcium deposits come from your diet
when instead it only comes from your
bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis and when you get these
things you need more calcium not less
then there's cramps and twitches you
wake up in the middle of the night and
your foot is all cramped up around your
neck you say Lord take me from the knee
down I'm not going to make it till
morning we've all experienced that
that's very common then there's PMS
premenstrual syndrome you know the
emotional and physical stuff the medical
treatment of choice for PMS is what we
call a hysterical ectomy it's been
shortened to hysterectomy that's a
hundred-year-old
the doctors do about 285,000 unnecessary
hysterical ectomy a year but it makes
Mercedes payments so they do them even
the AMA said they're unnecessary but
they don't take their licenses away and
people keep going to them you imagine a
poor woman in her 30s she says doc you
got to do something every time I go out
to hang up the clothes my neighbor's
kids run down the basement screaming
which my own kids think I'm crazy my
husband's leaving me I'm gonna lose my
job you got to do something well the
University of California San Diego came
out three years ago now and said if you
just double the RDA of calcium intake
you'll get rid of 85% of the emotional
and physical symptoms of PMS and when
that came out there were huge lines
around the health food stores around the
blocks and people had sleeping bags
because it closed before they all got
their calcium and every person in line
was a man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that okay and lastly is low
back pain 85% of Americans get low back
pain with your work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks
doesn't matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebra whether you have a disc problem
or what not because if your disc doesn't
have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae have melted away what's going
to happen to the discs especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them I just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a muscle
relaxant you might get valium and a
muscle relaxant you get the laminectomy
you get your vertebrae fuse you might
get a disk operations they don't tell
you 75 percent of time you'll never be
the same again
right PMS you go to your ob/gyn you can
go to an internist you can go to a
family counselor a shrink or divorce
attorney cramps and twitches you go to a
neurologist you go to a sports medicine
doctor an internist bone spurs heel
spurs calcium deposits you go to a
Rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia go to shrinker a sleep clinic
or an internist hypertension you go to a
cardiologist and internist or a surgeon
arthritis a Rheumatologist a orthopedic
surgeon or an internist receding gums
you go to a dentist or a periodontist
osteoporosis you go to all those health
specialists including a tum salesman for
nothing more than a calcium deficiency
it cost you ten cents a day to deal with
now on the average because Americans
have insurance and we have Medicare and
Medicaid we spend on the average $25,000
to two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and we undergo five to ten
surgical procedures a year for a calcium
deficiency we beg the doctors to do it
we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you is diabetes everybody is touched by
diabetes it's the number three cause of
death and adults in the United States
number three cause of death
and it has terrible complications and
side effects diabetes the side effects
include blindness of many kinds then
there's a kidney failure with dialysis
and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds of
course that contributes the number one
cause of death then there is amputations
everybody ought to have one of those
because they're totally paid for and
their health thing because they assume
that you're not just gonna get one
because you want to get everything on
your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter life span than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals as a pretty profound
statement we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
Official Journal of the American science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly journal is August 1957
well the two trace minerals that you can
get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vanadium vanadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vanadium
alone will replace insulin in antal
onset diabetics which represent 85% of
all diabetics of course they can't quit
their insulin cold turkey they got to
gradually wean off of it takes four to
six months for most people to slowly
wean off of insulin if they're taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and
vanadium now to me this is criminal
because if you write to hills packing
company that makes science dot dog for
the right over here in Topeka Kansas so
they manufacture signs diet dog food and
other signs diet product high tech foods
for animals if you write them and say
how many minerals exactly is in science
diet for dog food they'll write you back
and say there's 40 minerals you're right
checkerboard square in st. Louis Ralston
Koreans say just how many minerals are
in your rat pellets for laboratory rats
and they'll say there's 28 minerals
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new hundred-dollar bill if you can find
me a human infant formula and a grocery
store that has more than 11 so our dogs
get 40 minerals there's a Mike Murphy of
a since dog never seems to get sick
because he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals
so our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get
28 minerals and our human infants get 11
is that fair
no that's called fraud doesn't matter if
you're talking about SMA Similac I Samil
pro soy B fact that's why they call
Similac Similac because it lacks
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly can't
depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
ground up rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
dolomite limestone calcium carbonate
clays of various kinds mount marula
Knight clay sea bed minerals Tom's
they're only eight to 12 percent
absorbable when you reach age 35 to 40
it drops down to three to five percent
and I have to tell you a story here I
ran into a guy at a meeting like this up
at Grand Rapids Michigan and this fella
owns a port-a-potty business you know
that's that green or blue colored
outhouse man if we had only had one of
those back when I was a kid we had these
ones with splinters you know in the wood
he said I see something that describes
that my port-a-potty business I said
what's that
he says when we take those things back
to the shop to clean him out with the
pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath them because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it every
time we clean one of those out we find
hundreds of vitamin tablets and said
well how do you know they're vitamin
tablets he said well that's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
teragrams em one-a-day Centrum he says
come here and he takes me out in the
back of his shop and there's this
literal mountain of all these vitamin
pills he got out of his porta-potties if
you read the labels on those multiples
they say your iron that comes in the
form of iron oxide what is iron oxide
rust you might as well just go out to an
old railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement but that's what they're
dead
I'll show you how bad it is if you take
something like calcium lactate which is
a common metallic mineral let's say it's
a calcium tab of calcium lactate a
thousand milligrams if you take two of
those you're not getting two thousand
milligrams of calcium in fact I have
people all the time say well I took lots
of calcium doc I hear you on the radio
talking about calcium and arthritis and
I took two thousand milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse as that what kind
of calcium you taken they said calcium
lactate well there's your problem
because only 250 milligrams of that is
metallic calcium so let's say absorb 10%
of that then the other 750 milligrams is
lactose or milk sugar so 10% of 250 is
25 so if you take two of those tablets
you're not getting 2,000 you're getting
50 milligrams so to get what you need
you need to take 90 of those tablets a
day you need to take 30 with each meal
and you got 59 more minerals to go then
there's those people who want to do
things naturally let's see if you can do
anything good with 10 pounds of spinach
and let's be fairly sieving at a
thousand milligrams of magnesium and I
pick magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll rights part
of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 grams and
10 pounds of spinach you got 4500 and 40
grams of which most of that 97% is water
let's say have one gram of chlorophyll
in that 10 pounds of spinach there's 50
milligrams of magnesium you got to
divide that into the thousand you want
you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 pounds of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to go okay so you got to be a
pretty big person to accomplish all this
even as big as I am you can't get it
done so I preferred a supplemental
rather than do those things then of
course during the 60s the agricultural
industry came up with chelated minerals
because farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar if something goes into
an animal's mouth and have 99 cents come
out in the manure I have to really thank
farmers for being that clever and
chelated minerals are just metallic
minerals with an amino acid or protein
or enzyme
wrapped around the metal atom and
increase the absorbability to 40% then
the health food industry jumped on that
right away because it was a major
improvement and absorbability of
minerals the most efficient way to
absorb minerals is liquid they're very
small particle size they are seven
thousand times smaller than a red blood
cell and their negatively charged so you
actually have an electrical or magnetic
gradient that concentrates these
minerals plants have a very interesting
part to play in colloidal minerals
remember we said that plants cannot
create minerals they're not in the soil
plants can't make them at any rate
metallic minerals are taken up by plants
when they're in the soil plants convert
them in their tissues to colloidal
minerals and this is how we store
minerals in our body this is how we use
minerals in our body this is how we
transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal farm
well our plants our crops don't have
much in the way of colloidal minerals in
them because we don't have any metallic
minerals in our soil there are these
minerals important you bet your life
they're important information and
statements regarding dietary supplements
discussed have not been evaluated by the
Food and Drug Administration and are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease